la ministre des affaires sociales et de
la santé l'invité de preuves par 3
marisol touraine bonsoir bonsoir et
merci de votre présence à ce rendez-vous
de public sénat avec dailymotion et l'
agence france presse qui sera représenté
ce soir par hervé lyonnais spécialiste
des questions sociales donc de la
réforme des retraites les syndicats même
réformiste d'ailleurs demande appelle
les députés à améliorer encore le texte
ne nous en parlerons et puis avec
perrine tarneaud de public sénat nous
parlerons de santé publique alors que
vous venez présenter une nouvelle
stratégie pour lutter contre les
inégalités avec notamment la gratuité
chez le médecin votre ministère madame
touraine est très vaste à la fois très
technique mais très proche également des
préoccupations des français es ce que
vous avez l'impression d'être depuis que
vous êtes à ce poste atteinte de
gestion' it aiguë vous l'avez dit c'est
un des ministères qui est le plus en
prise avec la réalité quotidienne de la
vie des français et moi j'ai depuis un
an la fierté d'avoir engagé des
politiques qui concernent les français
au quotidien qu'il s'agisse d'améliorer
leurs remboursements de permettre la
gratuité d'olive et j'ai de permettre la
gratuité de la contraception pour les
mineures de faire en sorte que la
sécurité des médicaments soient
renforcés c'est ce que nous avons fait
pour la pilule par exemple
cela c'est la vie quotidienne des
français comme très concrètement la
revalorisation l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire ou évidemment en ce moment la
réforme des retraites qui concerne
chacun d'entre nous y sommes entendus
donc claude bartolone parce que c'est
lui qui a poussé ce coup de gueule
devant les parlementaires socialistes la
gestionnaire aiguë ça suffit en fait ils
visent le gouvernement vous êtes
ministre de simplement administrer les
choses et donc de vous piéger vous même
le gouvernement depuis un peu plus d'un
an qu'il est aux responsabilités il a un
cap celui de la transformation à gauche
la transformation à gauche de notre
société répondre aux attentes des
français le mariage pour tous ça n'est
pas de la gestion c'est une réforme
profonde la réforme des retraites que je
porte aujourd'hui cela répond à des
réalités les attentes de la part de nos
concitoyens que ja oui je pourrais
énumérer que je voulais dire par là
c'est que nous avons un cap ce cap c'est
celui de la transformation
c'est l'obsession de l'emploi
l'obsession de la croissance faire en
sorte que nos concitoyens vivent mieux
claude bartelone vous estimez qu'il ya
le débat est trop intense sur la pause
ou la non pause fiscale donc en quelque
sorte c'est ça mais le fait que jean
marc ayrault donc assume les os il le
dit lui même mais augmenter et augmenter
les impôts madame antoine est ce que
c'est du courage les impôts c'est un
moyen si nous avions pu ne pas augmenter
les impôts nous l'aurions fait mais nous
avons dû à notre arrivée aux
responsabilités mettre en place une
politique qui est aussi passé par de la
fiscalité mais pas uniquement par de la
fiscalité parce qu'aujourd'hui le débat
se concentre sur les impôts mais je veux
rappeler qu' il y a eu aussi des
économies importantes réalisées et la
mise en place d'une politique de soutien
à la compétitivité des entreprises c'est
par cet
assortiment de mesures si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi que nous relançons la
croissance que nous relançons la
croissance et l'activité l'emploi et les
premiers résultats sont là donc il ne
s'agit pas de nier qu'il y a eu des
augmentations d'impôts d'ailleurs ils
sont là
mais aujourd'hui et le président de la
république l'a indiqué la part des
économies va être plus importante et au
four l'objectif que nous nous fixons il
reste le même la croissance et l'emploi
et ne faisons pas de cette question des
impôts la seule question qui serait
celle de la politique que nous suivons
assumer la baisse des dépenses ça c'est
plus glorieux c'est plus et plus
courageux en tous les cas ça sert de
plus difficile néanmoins sur une
question cv ça n'est pas facile de
présenter des hausses de fiscalité
encore une fois c'est nous pouvions
éviter si nous avions pu éviter
certaines hausses de fiscalité nous
l'aurions fait simplement les économies
elle porte aussi sur des politiques
auquel les français sont attachés donc
il faut avoir conscience que nous sommes
dans une période qui appelle des efforts
efforts fiscaux efforts en matière de
l'état aussi un fort bel et bien sûr
c'est d'ailleurs l'ensemble de
l'administration d'état fait des efforts
tout à fait important puisque les
économies sur le budget de l'état seront
historiques et celle des collectivités
locales aussi point précis vous avez
assumé pour reprendre l'expression du
premier ministre la réduction du
quotient familial est ce que vous pouvez
confirmer que les familles vont
finalement gardé leurs réductions
d'impôts pour leurs enfants scolarisés à
partir du secondaire le ministre de
l'économie des finances présentera le
projet de loi de finances demain au
placement familial c'est une île à il a
dit ce matin de façon extrêmement clair
que cela ferait partie du débat au
parlement et rigueur le parlement pourra
exprimer ce qui est sa priorité ou sa
préoccupation les débats au parlement
doivent être ouverts nous allons nous
avons une double exigence qui est celle
de permettre parlementaire de jouer leur
rôle qui est celui de relayer des
préoccupations et de porter des
améliorations aux textes que nous
présentons est en même temps de garantir
que l' équilibre des textes que nous
présentons est respectée parce
qu'évidemment
construisons nous construisons des
réformes qui est dont l'esprit est l'
équilibre doivent être respectés
d'accord attendant ce débat non pour
savoir si effectivement vont renoncer
pour les familles c'est sur quoi je veux
insister ici c'est que la politique
familiale du gouvernement est une
politique forte et ambitieuse
l'autre politique elle ne consiste pas
seulement à réorienter les ressources en
direction des familles les plus modestes
même si je veux insister sur le fait que
en baissant l'aide fiscale aux familles
les plus aisées nous allons pouvoir
encore se sentent aujourd'hui le savait
l'aide nous nous renforçons l'aide aux
familles modestes et en particulier aux
familles nombreuses mais nous aidons
toutes les familles à travers une
politique résolue de d'accueil du jeune
enfant de l'enfant de moins de 3 ans et
cela c'est une politique qui s'adresse
aussi aux familles des classes moyennes
parce que nous savons que la
conciliation entre la vie
professionnelle et la vie familiale
cela concerne l'ensemble des femmes
répudiées d'ensemble fm vous avez cité
françois hollande est jamais sa
popularité n'avait été aussi bas c'est
ce que cela vous inquiète
la popularité je les ai souvent dit on
préfère qu'elles soient élevés puis est
très faible mais la priorité pour un
président de la république pour un
gouvernement se dé répondre aux
exigences de l'intérêt général et aux
exigences du pays la situation de crise
dans laquelle se trouve notre pays
appelle des mesures courageuses résolu
qui ne sont pas nécessairement populaire
et c'est cela que fait le président de
la république et je sais que sa
préoccupation c'est de permettre à notre
pays d'aller de l'avant ça n'est pas de
se préoccuper de l'état de sa popularité
cinq mois après mois bien sûr du sexe
mais l'essentiel c'est que au bout du
mandat la france aille mieux les
français soient plus sûrs d'eux mêmes
plus à même d'affronter l'avenir c'est
cela l'exigence qui pèse sur les épaules
françois mitterrand vous savez le
précédent président de la république
était très obsédé par sa courbe de
popularité
à l'évidence cela n'a pas permis de
convaincre les français la ministre de
la santé il a formulé médical je les lui
dans le figaro qui ne ménage pas ses
critiques certes mais la greffe ne prend
pas il ya un rejet du chef de l'état
écrit ce journal encore une fois
l'exigence de mesures
difficiles courageuses s'impose
l'exigence pour nous c'est de répondre
aux préoccupations des français de faire
en sorte que année après année mois
après mois si possible mais année après
année eh bien la france et les français
à mieux notamment sur le terrain du
chômage et puisque le président s'est
engagé à ce que la courbe du chômage
s'inverse d'ici la fin de l'année c'est
un objectif pour nous tous et il faut
souligner que d'ores et déjà la courbe
du chômage des jeunes s'est inversée
depuis plusieurs mois c'est un point
important et qui est porteur d'espoir
vous parler du courage du chef de l'état
est ce que vous diriez la même chose à
propos de vos collègues manuel valls qui
estime que les roms dans leur majorité
ne veulent pas s'intégrer en france en
raison de leur mode de vie vous avez
vous aidé le même a vaincu public c'est
à la fois des valeurs et des règles et
nous devons rappeler à la fois les
valeurs de la république et les règles
de cet arrêt pour les roms ceux qui
vivent sur notre territoire doivent
respecter les règles lorsque de la
république française lorsque ça n'est
pas le cas ils sont évidemment amené à
quitter notre territoire mais nous
devons avoir une politique est
récent selon vous est-ce que par essence
les roms ont vocation à quitter notre
pays est encore jeune mais les roms
doivent respecter les règles de la
république il ne s'agit pas mais je me
suis dit il ne s'agit pas de mode de vie
il ne s'agit pas de différend il n'a
capacité à s'intégrer sur notre
territoire il y à des hommes et des
femmes qui tous n'ont pas les mêmes
modes de vie mais qui tous doivent
respecter les règles de la république et
lorsqu'il ne les respectent pas ils
doivent quitter notre territoire et les
roms sont dans cette situation là s'ils
respectent les règles ils peuvent rester
sur notre terre une minorité selon ces
insectes les règles c'est une minorité
jeudi là l'enjeu il est celui du respect
des règles la république ce sont des
règles c'est aussi des valeurs et je
crois que nous devons avoir le respect
des personnes et le respect des valeurs
et des règles de notre rythme vous êtes
tout à l'heure où tu mettais du côté des
associations qui s'indignent qui
dénoncent ces stéréotypes ou partager
l'opinion manuel valls il a dit à la
fois qu'il y avait le respect des règles
et qu' il y avait une intégration
impossible et lorsqu'on leur majorité
les roms doivent partir car elles ne
peuvent pas s'intégrer dans la
république mais ceux qui s'intègrent et
respectent les règles n'ont pas à être
mise en cause et je ne crois pas que
cela puisse être l'esprit de ce qu'a dit
le ministre de l'intérieur en tous les
cas il soulève une polémique elle est
infondée pour vous la polémique n'a pas
lieu d'être dès lors que l'on rappelle
dès lors que l'on rappelle que on se
fixe par rapport aux règles de la
république il ne s'agit pas de
considérer que telle ou telle population
par principe ne respectent pas les
règles simplement on se met en situation
de constater si les règles de la
république sont bien respectés encore
une fois tout le monde souhaite que
l'ordre soit évidemment
sanctuariser et en même temps cela doit
s'accompagner d'une grande humanité et
du respect des valeurs de notre
république notre république elle est
accueillante dès lors on accepte que
c'est un peu différent quand même de
celle de votre collègue question rapide
est ce qu'il faut changer la loi pour
faciliter le travail la nuit dans
certains magasins je fais référence à la
fermeture décidée par la justice du
magasin sephora sur les champs elysées
oui osons style de changement de loi je
ne suis pas certaine il doit y avoir des
discussions des négociations lorsque
c'est jugé nécessaire entre les
entreprises et leurs salariés mais ne
faisons pas comme si la nouvelle règle
devait être de travailler le plus
possible tubes plus tard possible et
disons le plus longtemps d'accord on va
parler du travail dans un instant avec
la réforme des retraites est ce qu'il
faut donner le droit de vote aux
élections locales à 16 ans et votre
ministre de la famille madame bertinotti
et lens libe dominique bertinotti a
indiqué qu'un groupe de travail était en
train de réfléchir à cette perspective
je crois qu'il faut être prudent pour ce
qui est de l'ouverture du droit de vote
la réflexion est engagée et nous verrons
bien si elle peut aboutir le coup d'en
être prudent
parce que la saison c'est vrai on peut
peut-être avoir un statut de pré
majorité le codeem quelques secondes
quel succès quels sont les droits liés à
la pré majorité puisque il est des
situations dans lesquelles on reconnaît
une pré majorité par exemple en matière
de sexualité est donc le sac à main
voilà donc il ya plusieurs âges qui sont
différents et c'est la raison pour
laquelle une réflexion est engagée pour
savoir s'il peut faire l'amour
à 15 ans ne peut pas voter avant 18 ans
écoutez donc la réflexion est engagée
encore une fois moi je souhaite que cela
se fasse avec prudence on n'est pas sûr
donc cette mesure figurera dans la
prochaine étape à la réflexion n'est pas
à ce stade abouti nicolas sarkozy reste
mis en examen dans le volet abus de
faiblesse de l'affairé bettencourt alors
qu il avait entendu en haute savoie il
annoncé qu'il avait en tête un
calendrier politique de retour beaucoup
de ténors de l'ump dénonce un
acharnement
est ce que vous pensez ou est ce que
vous espérez que son retour butera sur
un obstacle judiciaire la justice fait
son travail elle est indépendante et moi
je n'espère rien je n'attends rien en la
matière nicolas sarkozy décidera s'il
souhaite se représenter à l'élection
présidentielle ou à une autre élection
mais en tout cas le calendrier
judiciaire il est indépendant et il
n'appartient pas d'interférer avec ce
cas lors du chargement pg je moi je ne
commente pas les décisions de justice je
ne vois pas pourquoi les décisions de
justice arrangerait dans certains cas et
et contreviendrait à certains plans dans
d'autres on trouve toujours matière à se
réjouir ou à se désoler des décisions de
justice donc le mieux c'est de ne pas
les commenter et de laisser la justice
en toute indépendance faire son travail
les lyonnais donc de l' agence
france-presse va nous rejoindre
maintenant pour parler de la réforme des
retraites que vous portez marisol
touraine sous les critiques on va
reparler d'ailleurs et hausses d'impôts
du mois des prélèvements pour la
financer et on l'a vu sondages encore
le scepticisme l'emportent dans
l'opinion alors voici une nouvelle
réforme de retraites pas encore la
réforme sophie normand
mini réforme maxi cotisation c'est en
substance la critiques assénées par les
détracteurs de la réforme des retraites
version héros au coeur du projet de loi
il y à bien une hausse des prélèvements
ils seront progressifs et toucheront
salariés des employeurs le financement
du régime général passera aussi par un
allongement de la durée de cotisation au
rythme d'un trimestre tous les trois ans
en 2035 il faudra donc travailler 43 ans
pour bénéficier d'une retraite à taux
plein le dispositif concernera les
salariés du public et du privé mais pas
avant 2020 pour eric woerth ancien
ministre de nicolas sarkozy père de la
réforme des retraites de 2010 le
gouvernement manque de courage et à
pattes rouges du tout ce contrat un
exercice de lâcheté politique formidable
et c'est pas une référence et une
augmentation des taxes si une
augmentation des taxes et réformer le
système des retraites en tout cas
essayer de régler les problèmes
financiers des retraites uniquement par
des cotisations c'est vraiment là c'est
vraiment un train à côté de la plaque
avancée sociale majeure la création d'un
conte pénibilité les salariés qui auront
exercé un métier difficile pourront dès
2015 accumuler des points et partir
plutôt une mesure qui s'additionnent aux
dérogations qui existe déjà pour les
invalidités par exemple ou plus
récemment les salariés qui ont commencé
à travailler avant 20 ans et qui
pourront s'arrêter à 60 ans à la fin de
la décennie c'est ainsi un salarié sur
deux qui pourra techniquement partir en
retraite avant 62 ans et ce avec une
pension complète des exceptions qui
viennent s'ajouter à des prévisions de
chômage déjà très optimiste entre 5 et
7% alors même que la france n'est pas
revenu en dessous d'eux 8 ou 9% depuis
très longtemps et que les prévisions ne
l'anticipent à une baisse du taux de
chômage rapide sceptiques aussi la
commission européenne c'est avec
méfiance que les réformes à la française
sont suivis par hbo celle où le
président de la commission josé manuel
barroso table lui sur un départ en
retraite à 65 ans
voilà c'est ce qu'ils recommandent donc
le président de la commission européenne
vos questions sur cette réforme qui
serait encore plus âprement débattus
dans quelques jours au parlement pas
marisol touraine oui madame la ministre
cette réforme d'abord un objectif
financier celui de combler un déficit on
parlait de 20 milliards en 2020 si on ne
faisait rien mais on se rend compte que
finalement vous combler le déficit
essentiellement du régime général c'est
à dire un peu plus de 7 milliards alors
pour les 13 autres milliards d'ici 2020
comment fait-on cette réforme n'a pas
simplement un objectif financier cette
réforme elle a la volonté d'apporter un
horizon et des perspectives aux
générations qui s'engagent dans la vie
active ou sont au milieu de leur vie
active parce que si nous ne faisons rien
alors nous ouvrons un grand la porte à
la privatisation de notre système ou en
tout cas à une partie de notre système
et donc c'est une réforme qui a un enjeu
financier parce que il faut avoir le
courage de dire que nous devons trouver
des ressources pour garantir dans
l'avenir le financement de nos régimes
de retraite mais c'est aussi une réforme
qui a un objectif de rééquilibrage en
termes de justice de notre système de
retraite parce qu'il n'est pas juste que
la situation des femmes soit à ce point
dégradée par rapport à celle des hommes
parce qu'il n'est pas juste que les
conditions de travail ne soient pas
prises en compte pour définir le mode de
départ en retraite est donc l'enjeu des
conditions de travail ou un les coûts du
fuel et en avant le précédent mais le
précédent gouvernement a mis en avant la
notion d'invalidité et lorsque
j'entendais eric woerth je me disais que
puisqu'il parlait de mots comme lâcheté
ou autre qu' il ne manquez pas d'air si
vous me passez l'expression un peu
triviale parce que ce qui a caractérisé
sa réforme c'est le mépris mépris des
français en particulier de ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler jeunes mépris de
ceux qui sont usés par le travail
puisque au fond il a mis en place une
commission qui regardent le dossier
médical des gens et leur permet ou pas
de partir en retraite plus tôt mais
l'invalidité ça n'a jamais été une
situation où de pénibilité et c'est
toute la différence que d'ailleurs
souligner les organisations à syndicale
entre l'invalidité et la pénibilité mais
moi je veux répondre à votre question
sur la situation financière en 2020 on a
beaucoup évoqué ce chiffre de 20
milliards et il est juste c'est celui du
conseil d'orientation des retraites mais
il est global c'est à dire qu'il
comporte notamment tout ce qui a trait
au régime complémentaire de retraite qui
comme vous le savez ne dépendent pas du
gouvernement mais des partenaires
sociaux et la réforme que nous
présentons elle permet de financer le
régime général mais elle permet aussi
d'apporter des ressources nécessaires à
haut régime des fonctionnaires puisque
ils ont un régime différent de celui des
salariés du privé et c'est la raison
pour laquelle on est c'est la raison
pour laquelle je me spéciaux mais tous
les régimes spéciaux non mais les
régimes spéciaux c'est un régime des
médecins aussi par c'est à dire la
caisse
gym on trouve de nouvelles ressources
pour l'ensemble des régimes je veux
insister là dessus puisque la hausse des
cotisations elle va concerner aussi les
fonctionnaires et les salariés des
régimes spéciaux
là le report de la revalorisation de la
retraite l'année prochaine des retraités
va concerner les retraités de la
fonction publique ceux des régimes
spéciaux comme ceux des nations ma prime
estimation nous allons à l'équilibré en
2020 et en 2035 qui sont les deux
horizons que nous avons fixés dans
l'ensemble des régimes je veux insister
sur ce point parce que même si des
règles différentes continue d'exister
entre les différents régimes l'effort
qui est demandé à l'ensemble des
français est le même il n'ya pas des
français qui ne participent pas à
l'effort collectif demandé pour la
sauvegarde de nos retraites à l'avenir
nous parler de monsieur eric woerth tout
à l'heure c'est vrai que vous tapez
beaucoup sur la réforme de 2010 mais
beaucoup sur les nôtres enfin si je
crois que vous avez commencé
puisque puisque s'est
mêlé au moins elle vous êtes quand même
pas mal parce que enfin lui dit que sans
cette réforme sans le recul de l'âge de
60 à 62 ans ça serait non pas 20
milliards que deux
de déficit à combler d'ici 2020 mais 50
milliards
merci finalement souviens très
précisément c'est ce que disait le
précédent gouvernement lorsqu'il a
présenté sa réforme en 2010 et je ne
m'en souviens puisque
effectivement j'étais responsable pour
le parti socialiste à l'époque dans
l'opposition les 30 milliards non parce
que ils nous disaient zéro déficit en
2020 sa réforme elle prétendait combler
le trou des régimes de retraite aggravé
la crise est aggravée en quelques mois
en quelques mois nous nous sommes
aperçus que les résultats n'étaient pas
là puisque dès 2011 il a fallu indiqué
que des efforts seraient nécessaires et
une nouvelle réforme s'imposerait donc
je crois que mon donneur de leçons
monsieur woerth n'est pas crédible parce
que pour donner des leçons il faut
d'abord avoir des résultats et les
résultats ils manquent cruellement aux
gouvernements précédents y aurait cette
réforme madame la ministre est aussi une
réforme que vous voulez juste et c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de mesures de
justice mais pourtant je voudrais vous
interroger sur quelques petits points
qui me qui me pose question par exemple
ce conte pénibilité quand vous êtes
artisan
ou que vous avez simplement un ou deux
salariés vous fait le même travail mais
vous n'êtes pas considéré comme salarié
donc vous pouvez pas ouvrir de comptes
pénibilité la pénibilité concerne les
salariés pas les professions libérales
qui ont la possibilité de valoriser sur
les berges qui ont la possibilité de
définir leurs conditions de travail
l'objectif de ce conte de prévention de
la pénibilité c'est quoi c'est de faire
en sorte que celles et ceux qui ont
travaillé dans des conditions
identifié comme étant pénibles puissent
avoir des contreparties par exemple en
se formant au cours de leur carrière
pour changer de métier ou en partant
plus tôt à la retraite parce qu'ils sont
usés mais ça aussi pour objectif de
d'amener les entreprises et les chefs
d'entreprises donc par exemple les
artisans à changer les conditions de
travail dans lesquelles ils évoluent et
c'est pour cela que les entreprises à
contribuer ou simplement avec un seul ou
avec un ou deux salariés ils pourront
plus facilement c'est en général ce qui
se passe transformer leurs conditions de
travail et adapter la façon dont ils
réalisent leur production voilà pour les
artisans oui alors peut-être un autre
petit point aussi de justice comment
peut-on expliquer que un retraité très
aisé
à quitte finalement une une csg de 6,6
pour cent et qu'un actif très jeune au
smic lui il acquitte 7,5 là vous évoquez
il y à une
cg qui ne concerne pas la réforme des
retraites
c'est une des bases de la fiscalité de
façon à répondre parce que c'est une
question qui vient régulièrement mais je
pense la parution du rapport moreau pour
une fois c'est une proposition parmi
d'autres encore
attention à ne pas donner le sentiment
que au fond il s'agissait d'additionner
l'ensemble des mesures du rapport - de
madame moreau et sa commission avait
identifié cette piste là mais auquel cas
nous n'aurions pas fiscalisés les
compléments de retraite lorsque l'on a
plus de trois enfants ou reporter la
revalorisation de la retraite de six
mois au fond la question et je suis
frappé de voir que pour une fois on nous
demande d'augmenter un impôt puisque
cela revenait à augmenter ce taux de le
modeler de csg ça revenait à augmenter
un impôt de faire contribuer les
retraités comme comme
les organisations syndicales et c'est le
choix d'ailleurs que nous avons fait
c'est de faire porter l'effort sur les
cotisations et donc de cibler l'effort
des retraités sur le report de leur
revalorisation
qui touche d'ailleurs les petites
retraites je me dis mamie question de la
csg pourra être évoqué le cas échéant à
d'autres occasions mais au fond nous
c'est ce que c'est ce qu'évoque certains
du côté des organisations syndicales je
ne sais pas si ce serait le choix du
gouvernement nous n'avons pas avancé
suffisamment dans nos décisions pour que
je puisse vous répondre mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que les décisions sont
cohérentes on additionne pas des mesures
les unes aux autres de la cotisation
pour les actifs de la csg pour les
retraités donc nous avons fait le choix
de nous concentrer sur les cotisations
qui sont identifiés comme étant le mode
de financement classiques
directement madame la ministre
il est question de compenser pour 2014
la hausse des cotisations des
entreprises comme on fait de vous vous
avez déjà refusé toute nouvelle hausse
de ses jets ou de tva donc ce sera
confirmé d'ailleurs demain l'occasion de
la présentation du budget nous nous
sommes engagés à ce qu'il n'y ait ni
hausse de tva supplémentaire ni hausse
de csg il s'agit de financer la
politique familiale cela se fera sur le
budget de l'état c'est à dire à travers
la politique budgétaire des économies
qui sont faites d écouter les économies
qui sont faites ailleurs les ressources
qui sont appelés à la fiscalité déjà
prévu et qui nous permet de financer nos
politiques familiales nous permettront
de finances qui sont prévus pour le
budget de l'état pardon nous permettront
de financer la politique familiale
compensation de la hausse et que c'est
fait
nullement d'un absolument pas deux il
n'y a pas de hausse dédié pour cette
politique familiale où allez vous
trouver cet argent dans les économies
que nous faisons et qui sont très
importantes vous le savez nous avons
annoncé 15 milliards d'économies pas
trop pressé d'aller chercher le budget
oui mais ça fait partie du budget de
l'état donc l'état s'engage à garantir
le maintien de la politique familiale
bien évidemment à hauteur de ce qu'elle
est et à faire les économies
ces serres parlé hier pour financer
cette réponse ferait pas de compensation
sous forme de hausses d'impôts voilà qui
est dit là alors merci avec l'une des
dernières questions vous avait vanté
l'action du parlement tout à l'heure en
matière de fiscalité marisol touraine
parce que par exemple ou compter sur le
parlement pour améliorer votre réforme
sur les retraites puisque c'est ce que
demandent notamment les syndicats la
cfdt qui veut des réformes de justice
encore
débat va avoir lieu des améliorations
peuvent évidemment être introduite dès
lors que comme je les dis toujours les
jeunes pour la mission dit tout à
l'heure il s'agit de faire en sorte que
l' équilibre financier et social de la
retraite parce que préserver que son
équilibre ne soient pas bousculés très
bien débat à suivre à partir du mois
d'octobre merci encore une fois hier
mais le 7 octobre effectivement ça
l'assemblée nationale perrine tarneaud
de public sénat nous rejoint maintenant
donc pour la troisième partie de cette
émission qui est consacré à la santé à
la santé publique puisque vous venez de
présenter madame la ministre votre
nouvelle stratégie nationale de santé
avec comme points forts l'instauration
du tiers payant chez le médecin une
mesure qui divise la profession
d'ailleurs faustine saint geniès
une simple carte vitale pour régler sa
consultation chez le médecin ce sera
possible pour les patients d'ici 2017
marisol touraine vient de l'annoncer le
tiers payant s'appliquera chez
l'ensemble des généralistes à la fin du
quinquennat les patients n'auront alors
plus rien à débourser lors d'une
consultation chez un médecin
conventionné la mesure s'appliquera
d'abord aux plus démunis qui évite
souvent de consulter par manque de
moyens une bonne nouvelle pour ce
généraliste à aubervilliers en
seine-saint-denis la précarité augmente
en france les gens se soignent mal
attendent et la finale aux riverains aux
urgences parce que la lp pas donc en
faisant cela on refera ce que souhaitent
actuellement la nouvelle gouvernance et
l'autre une gouvernance précédente aussi
c'est à dire permettre aux médecins de
proposer la même configuration de
règlement qu'à l'hôpital et donc à ce
moment là les patients viendront nous
voir sans réticence mais pour d'autres
médecins généraliser le tiers payant va
créer un véritable casse tête
administratif et surtout
déresponsabiliser les patients lorsque
vous supprimez les caisses la sortie
d'un supermarché les cadis sont
certainement plus rang plus que si les
gens payent ces 2000 question de bon
sens si demain la gratuité induit une
consommation supérieure alors que nous
sommes dans le cas d'une maîtrise des
dépenses d'assurance maladie ya tout
lieu quand même d'être inquiet la
question est donc de savoir si le fait
de ne rien payer va pousser à aller
davantage chez le médecin mais ce n'est
pas ce qui pèse le plus sur les comptes
de la branche maladie de la sécurité
sociale déjà déséquilibré pour des
raisons structurelles il faut revoir la
carte hospitalière
il faut revoir notre fièrement notre
appareil de production de médicaments il
faut donc traiter le sujet j'allais dire
dans les structures et non pas le faire
à la marge jeudi prochain le
gouvernement présentera son budget de la
sécurité sociale le déficit de la
branche maladie pourrait atteindre 7 à 8
milliards d'euros
voilà perrine tarneaud et avec nos pères
élevant soir lorsqu'une question à la
ministre sur des questions très diverses
de s'entêter nous concerne tous
exactement marisol touraine relations
avec les médecins était déjà un peu
tendus avec la généralisation du tiers
payant est ce que vous prenez pas le
risque de les braquer une fois de plus
je ne crois pas du tout d'ailleurs
l'accueil est favorable à cette mesure
parce que les médecins savent très bien
que c'est une mesure qui va dans le sens
de l'intérêt des français que les
français la plébiscitent on ne souhaite
qu'une seule chose oui mais michel
forcément ethnique critiques de la part
des médecins et des tons il énonce une
étatisation du système d'accès qui va
coûter cher 3 euros par acte plus de la
jasse pas du tout pas du tout à cela
nous travaillons maintenant concrètement
à la mise en place de ce dispositif qui
existe dans énormément de pays pour
lesquels dans lesquelles ça ne se
traduit pas par davantage de papiers ou
d'administration pour les professionnels
de santé je veux rappeler que ça fait
partie des préconisations de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé pour
garantir
l'accès aux soins de manière simple et
cela doit permettre d' ailleurs à des
français de ne pas aller à l'hôpital où
le tiers-payant existèrent concrètement
on n'avance pas l'argent ça n'est pas
que ce soit gratuit 1 je veux insister
là dessus parce que ça coûte de l'argent
ça n'est pas gratuit tout simplement
on n'a pas les écouter ce qui se passe
pour les médicaments aussi un problème
pour les médicaments long puisque les
médicaments doivent être prescrits donc
l'eau n'en faut oui mais là ça n'est pas
le fait que vous mettiez votre carte
vitale chez le pharmacien c'est
peut-être le fait qu'on vous en prescrit
trop et je veux dire que l'entente
qu'elle responsabilisation en france des
passionnés ça ça fait partie des
discours habituel que l'on entend aucune
étude ne vient confirmer cela à
l'étranger où le tiers payant existe
c'est-à-dire concrètement où les
patients allemands des pays bas par
exemple vous et ne font pas la vence du
prix de la consultation on n'a pas
constaté d'augmentation dé consommation
médicale et puis vous savez aujourd'hui
le tiers payant est déjà pratiqué pour
les bénéficiaires de la cmu et on n'a
pas constaté daf l'action des actes mais
en france ce qui est problématique c'est
peut-être pas plus les visites chez le
généraliste mais notamment je pense aux
gens les moins favorisés les visites
chez le dentiste ou chez l'ophtalmo
enfin oui mais là ce qui est en jeu
c'est de faire en sorte qu'ils puissent
trouver des consultations à 1 tarifs
remboursés par la sécurité sociale c'est
pour cela que j'ai lancé dès l'année
dernière une négociation qui a abouti
sur la maîtrise des dépassements
d'honoraires et je veux rappeler par
ailleurs que
les personnes qui ont la cmu ou qui
peuvent avoir la cmu à la part dont
l'aide à la complémentaire santé au
total ça fait 10 millions de personnes
ce qui est quand même beaucoup c'est dix
millions de personnes ont la garantie
que elles peuvent avoir une consultation
au tarif sécurité sociale quel que soit
le médecin qu'elles vont consulter vous
présenterez jeudi marisol touraine le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2014 est ce que
vous confirmez que le déficit global de
la sécurité sociale sera inférieur de 1
milliard inférieur à caen à quoi à
l'année précédente
écoutez le déficit de la sécurité
sociale sera meilleur enfin sera donc
moins élevé que celui
l'année dernière et je dois dire que les
données ms attendant ce recul oui tant
dans ce recul est dû pour l'assurance
maladie voilà autant dans son recul et
de façon beaucoup plus significatif
maladie et y compris et de façon
beaucoup plus significative que ce que
nous avions escompté lors des
estimations du mois de juin dernier de
faire je pense que nous pourrons
annoncer des chiffres encourageants et
satisfaisant mais le déficit de la
branche maladie lui l'augmentant des des
chiffres seront présentés samedi je dis
pardon et vous verrez que les données
sont tout à fait encourageants mais
quelle va être votre principal levier
d'action pour réduire le déficit de la
branche maladie est-ce que ça va être le
prix des médicaments qui va être encore
ciblé cette année la question du
médicament est une question tout à fait
importante vous le disiez tout à l'heure
nous consommons trop de médicaments dans
notre pays si on veut dire que nous
devons informer informer les français du
fait qu'il n'est pas nécessaire de
consommer autant de médicaments
encourager la prescription et l'achat de
médicaments génériques et faire en sorte
que dans les hôpitaux aussi on
prescrivent moins de médicaments je veux
devenir 10 et le frigia vivement il y
aura des délais des mesures en direction
du prix des médicaments des
l'encouragement au générique en
particulier et je lance d'ailleurs une
campagne d'information sur la vente par
internet des médicaments puisque cela
peut être donner le sentiment que le
médicament est un produit comme un autre
et favoriser la consommation de
médicaments nous rappelle dans cette
campagne que un médicament n'est pas un
produit comme un autre qu'il faut faire
attention à ce que l'on achète et qu'il
ne faut prendre de médicaments que
lorsque c'est absolument nécessaire dans
le prochain budget est ce que vous
renoncé à taxer le nutella à l'aspartame
les boissons énergisantes le vin
transformer bref tout ce qui est mauvais
pour la santé ce que vous renoncez à les
taxer ça ne figurera pas dans le projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire ça
n'a jamais fait partie des projets que
j'ai portés et donc parce que je ne
crois pas que nous résolvions des enjeux
majeurs de santé publique à travers des
taxes j'ai annoncé hier la stratégie
comportement quand même ça change les
comportements à condition de faire
pratiquer à condition de faire partie
d'une politique d'ensemble globale et
cohérente je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
se contenter d'avoir des mesures
disséminés qu'il soit rendu l'air ce
sont les cigarettes nous avons engagé il
ya eu une hausse au moins de juillet
dernier est donc cette hausse
s'accompagne d'une politique résolue
d'explication et de soutien à ceux qui
veulent arrêter de fumer on ne peut pas
dire que la lutte la fiscalité soit le
seul instrument de notre politique de
lutte contre le tabac mais vous évoquiez
la stratégie nationale de santé que j'ai
annoncé hier pour la première fois nous
mettons en place dans notre pays une
politique qu'il fait globale et qui fait
de la prévention la prévention elle
commence à l'école c'est l'éducation à
la santé c'est se fixer des objectifs de
santé publique et c'est permettre aux
médecins d'être rémunéré pour améliorer
la santé de nos concitoyens par des
actions de prévention est donc ça c'est
tout à fait nouveau je veux insister là
dessus c'est ce que font d'ailleurs
d'autres pays c'est ce qu' ils avons
pour notre part jamais engagé alors
justement concernant des comportements
en france plusieurs questions assez
précises quand par exemple va entrer en
vigueur l'interdiction de vapoter dans
les lieux publics je parle de la
cigarette électronique je ne peux pas
répondre précisément une étude une
consultation a été engagée auprès des
eaux d'aidé aux deux instances
juridiques de notre pays pour voir les
conditions et délais dans lesquels ça
peut intervenir mais je suis presque
tous les étés moi même je veux dire à
nos concitoyens qui sont de plus en plus
nombreux à utiliser la cigarette
électronique que ça n'est pas un produit
anodin et ça fait un peu chic et choc la
cigarette électronique on voit qu'il ya
un marketing très important autour de ce
produit
ça peut aider à arrêter de fumer et donc
dans ce c'est pour ça que je n'ai jamais
préconisé l'interdiction de la cigarette
électronique
contrairement à d'autres pays qui l'ont
purement et simplement interdite
ça n'est pas un produit comme un autre
et donc arrêté oui faut s'en servir pour
arrêter de fumer oui mais ça peut
inciter des jeunes en particulier qui
trouvent que c'est joli que c'est un peu
la tendance ça peut les inciter à venir
au tabac parce que j'ai de la nicotine
et la nicotine elle rend dépendants je
ne sais pas si vous avez vu marisol
touraine ces révélations d'une enquête
de que choisir
le vin le vin il ya eu 92 20 tester ils
étaient tous très contaminée aux
pesticides des vins à tous les prix bio
ou pas bio est ce que bordeaux
on va pas les citer d'études vous n'avez
pas vu ses études occupants c'est
extrêmement préoccupant et là il ya un
enjeu en termes de consommation et de
contrôle des produits que nous sommes
amenés à consommer parce que personne ne
dit qu'il ne faut pas ou qu'on ne peut
pas boire du vin de façon raisonnable je
crois que les contrôles doivent
évidemment je me permet de détecter des
solutions il faut une réglementation
lourde et fauche il faut que les
producteurs soient transparents sur les
produits qu'ils proposent à la
consommation de nos clients
réglementation côté si réglementation
est nécessaire
il y a nous le verrons mais en tout cas
il est bon que la transparence soit
faite c'est un début de prise de
conscience plusieurs personnalités
proches de votre majorité des citoyens
ne font leur entrée au comité national
d'éthique les responsables religieux
sont évincés est ce que vous leur faites
payer leur position hostile au mariage
pour tous sens il ne s'agit pas de faire
payer quoi que ce soit à qui que ce soit
non je le dis il faut que ce comité
consultatif national d'éthique est une
instance importante que nous sollicitons
beaucoup puissent maintenir l'esprit
mais on puisse exprimer la diversité de
la société française et c'est la
diversité des opinions qui est
représenté dans ce collectif les
l'éthique et les idées et tic peuvent
être portés par des personnes sensibles
religion sans être pour elle même ou
elle-même des religieux je crois que
cette composition reflète bien la
nouvelle composition de ce comité
reflète bien la diversité des
engagements et de
diversité des positions et des options
dans notre pays vous maintenez les
urgences de l'hôtel-dieu ouverte à paris
contre l'avis de l'ap-hp est ce que
c'est pour des raisons électorales
jusqu'aux élections municipales j'ai
indiqué que le projet de l'hôtel dieu
est un grand projet est que nous avons
besoin ans entre dans le centre de paris
de repenser l'offre de soins c'est ce
qui est engagé il y a un travail
d'évolution qui passe aussi par la
restructuration des urgences globalement
à paris ce que je souhaite c'est que
cette restructuration elle se fasse dans
la concertation dans le dialogue et de
manière progressive ça n'est que si nous
avons toutes les assurances nécessaires
que nous pouvons faire évoluer la
situation actuelle que la négociation et
la discussion avance dernière question à
la wii alors que j'ai la pause et bien
la politique on a fini avec toutes les
questions de bleu satiné
puiser
concernés évidemment à mais on a parlé
tout à l'heure de la réforme des
retraites vous avez critiqué eric woerth
qui s'exprimait dans le reportage
françois fillon s'est exprimé
aujourd'hui devant les parlementaires de
l'ump il était très très dure sur votre
réforme il a dit vous les socialistes
il s'adresse à vous vous êtes
disqualifié en fait tous cas depuis 20
ans car vous avez refusé toutes les
réformes précédentes il a parlé des deux
semaines vous estiment disqualifie que
répondez-vous à françois fillon que la
semaine qui vient de s'écouler est
plutôt une semaine au cours de laquelle
françois fillon s'est disqualifiée pour
porter un jugement sur les activités
politiques dans notre pays qu'il
s'agisse de ses propos sur le front
national qu'il s'agisse de ses propos en
russie particulièrement choquant sur la
politique française vis-à-vis de la
syrie ne sont à l'honneur ni de l'ump ni
de françois fillon donc effectivement en
matière de disqualification françois
fillon n'a de leçon à donner à personne
merci encore une fois d'avoir été avec
nous merci bonsoir à tout ça très vite
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
notre invité sur un françois rebsamen le
président des sénateurs ps